solve the absolute value of 3x minus 9
is equal to 0 and graph the solution on
a number line so let me just rewrite it
so we have the absolute value of 3x
minus 9 is equal to 0.
so if the absolute value of something is
equal to zero what can that something be
well the only thing that you could take
the absolute value of and get zero is
zero so that something has to be zero so
it has to be a zero inside of the
absolute value sign so we know that
three x minus nine
must be equal to zero if this was any
other non-negative value you would have
two values if this was a positive 2 you
would say 3x minus 9 could be positive 2
or negative 2. but when you're dealing
with 0 3x minus 9 has to equal 0. that's
the only way when you take the absolute
value you're going to get 0. so now we
just solve this we add 9 to both sides
of this equation
add 9 to both sides equation you get 3x
is equal to
9 divide both sides by 3
and you get x is equal to 9 over 3 or x
is equal to 3 and you're done and now we
just do the second part graph the
solution on a number line so let's graph
let's we have a number line here let me
draw one it's a number line i'll put
some negative values maybe we'll start
at negative two
negative one
zero
one
two
three
four
five could keep going on but the
solution is x is equal to three
x is equal to three so just graphing
down the number line we just put a
little dot at three that is the solution